il est 18 heures si vous nous rejoignez
en direct sur tv fil 78 heures d'une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction le point sur l'information
locale en ce 28 janvier 2015
voici les titres les cyclistes qui
défendront les couleurs tricolores aux
championnats du monde de février au
vélodrome national de montigny le
bretonneux sont venus à la rencontre de
la presse hier sont ils en mesure de
briller et de rapporter quelques
médailles le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer de nouvelles mesures pour
réduire le nombre d'accidents sur les
routes que faut-il en attendre invité
pascal lecourt membres de l'association
victimes de la route 78 jean yves petit
directeur du comité des yvelines de la
prévention routière
l'artiste japonais yuki chine où est
présente plus d'une centaine de ces
visages sculptés dans la pierre à la
salle d'exposition de guyancourt
découverte d'une oeuvre qui se veut est
un symbole de l'histoire passée et à
venir ce sera à la fin de cette édition
mais tout d'abord et comme chaque fin de
mois les chiffres du chômage dévoilés au
niveau national la tendance n'est pas
bonne plus 8000 chômeurs en décembre une
hausse sur 2014 de son 89000 demandeur
d'emploi en ile-de-france pôle emploi
enregistre également une hausse +0 1%
par rapport à novembre et surtout une
hausse sur un an de 5,9 pour cent un
total à ce jour de 161 1390 personnes à
la recherche de travail elle sans
surprise ce sont surtout les inscrits de
longue durée et qui paye le plus lourd
tribut plus 11,3 pour cent en un an sur
la région francilienne
à trois semaines du coup d'envoi des
mondiaux de cyclisme à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la france a
donc dévoilé sa sélection de coureurs et
sans grande surprise françois pervis va
défendre et ses trois titres mondiaux de
sprint sur piste il ne sera pas le seul
pour représenter les couleurs nationales
michael et demi d'euros passé les
troupes en revue
la liste des sélectionnés français pour
les championnats du monde sur piste est
tombé par surprise les têtes d'affiché
seront bien présentes au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
18 au 22 février les spectateurs
pourront voir en action grégory baugé
110 claire ou encore françois pervis sur
la vitesse thomas boudât et bryan
coquard sont tous alignés dans les
épreuves d'endurance une sélection
compétitive fois que j'ai joué un très
difficile puisque les critères étaient
précis donc les athlètes savez très bien
où ils allaient ils savaient qu'ils
allaient avoir une chance et comme on
leur a rappelé lors du bilan c'est que
l'équipe de france en donne une chance
par contre il ne faut pas la louper
puisque jour de la course il va falloir
être présent au jour j ai donc il faut
saisir sa chance et simplement nouvelle
coqueluche du cyclisme sur piste
tricolore françois pervis fait
logiquement partie de la sélection
française triple champion du monde à
cali en colombie en 2014 lit ni mon
teint n'arrivera pas dans les meilleures
conditions cette année le pistard a été
perturbée par des blessures pendant sa
préparation des doutes il y en a
forcément un petit peu parce que je suis
quand même
- je me sens moins fort que l'année
dernière à la même époque
donc là aujourd'hui je veux pas je peux
pas vous dire je vais gagner les trois
titres de champion du monde que j'ai
déjà gagné l'année dernière je vais
faire je fais avec
comme j'ai dit c'est comme ça c'est le
sport et puis moi je de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive je donnerai le meilleur de
moi même et je suis rien lâcher objectif
annoncé par la fédération française de
cyclisme récolter au minimum cinq
médailles sur ces championnats du monde
pour atteindre ce but les sportifs
compte sur le soutien du public français
sur nos voitures championnats du monde à
l'étranger bien sûr c'est chez nous ont
donc c'est un peu plus excitant mais moi
je pense que j'ai de revanche à prendre
par rapport à 2006 et puis et puis on
sait très bien que wade tous les
français qui étaient des arts à noah à
londres ont envie de nous voir briller
dans quelques semaines donc voilà après
ça ne de ne pas se laisser emballer
d'être trop excité par rapport à
l'événement le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines affiche
presque complet pour les cinq jours de
compétition le nouvel écrin du sport
français attend désormais le 18 février
pour vibrer au rythme des exploits du
champion tricolore en début de semaine
le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve a annoncé toute une série de
mesures afin de réduire le nombre de
tués sur les routes des mesures décidées
alors que pour l'année 2014 les chiffres
ne sont pas bons 3388 mort une
progression de 3,7 pour cent en un an je
reçoit en plateau à patrick le court
bonsoir vous êtes membre de
l'association sos victimes de la route
78 jean yves petit bonsoir directeur du
comité des yvelines de la prévention
routière je voudrais forcément vous
faire réagir sur les 26 mesures qui ont
été annoncées cela va de la baisse du
taux d'alcoolémie de 0 5 à 0 2 g par
litre de sang pour les conducteurs
novices à l'interdiction des oreillettes
casque ou autres écouteurs au volant est
ce que tout cela va dans le bon sens
voir comment ça peut être avec vous est
ce que ce sont des mesures que vous
saluer vous attendiez oui nous
nous selon la plupart des mesures qui ne
sont pas toutes des des nouveautés un
beau coup de mesures étaient déjà prévus
nous en avons déjà parlé
elle était déjà prévue et elles vont
être mises en oeuvre puisque le ministre
l'a décidé oui mais c'est un panel
complet qui visent toutes les les causes
et toutes les circonstances de la
sécurité routière
donc ce sont de bonnes mesures complètes
nous soutenons la plupart ce que vous
partagez cet avis parce qu'à un moment
certaines voix se sont fait entendre
pour dire que les mesures partait un peu
dans tous les sens qui avait beaucoup de
choses qu'il fallait se reconcentrer sur
peut-être l'essentiel la vitesse par
exemple aux autres
non mais tout à fait d'accord que
monsieur petit sur les mesures qui sont
prises
je trouve que ceux des bonnes mesures
c'est notre façon avec le niveau de
notre association
tout ce qui va dans le sens de réduire
le nombre de tués et de blessés graves
ou de blesser même légers seront sur les
routes va dans le bon sens si on rentre
un peu plus dans le détail sur la
question des écouteurs par exemple pour
ne pas déranger l'attention des
conducteurs là on n'interdit pas le
système intégré aux voitures par exemple
pour les téléphones il fallait pas aller
plus loin encore vous adresser à
marseille qui sont alors tous les deux
oui s'ils voulaient dans l'absolu il
faudrait interdire complètement le
téléphone quel que soit le mode de
téléphone mais on n'y arrivera pas comme
ça parce qu'on a cela c'est une étape
c'est une étape exactement est une étape
qui est déjà bonne puisque ça revient en
gros a supprimé le kit piéton en c'est
ça que ça veut dire et ça va évidemment
dans le bon sens
nous ce que nous souhaitons la
prévention routière dans l'absolu bien
évidemment ce serait d'interdire tous
les téléphones mais au moins que les
téléphones soient le plus automatisée
possible avec des commandes vocales par
exemple pour qu'ils aient le moins de
manipulations à faire pour éviter de
distraire l'attention du conducteur
ça va suffisamment loin il fallait aller
encore plus loin non je suis je rejoins
la une ce petit c'est vrai que bon
maintenant c'est vrai qu'avec les
technologies embarquées dans les
véhicules avec le bluetooth un n'a plus
besoin des des oreillettes ou s'est dit
c'est vrai que la tension permet quand
même de parler avec quelqu'un tout en
conservant
la vue sur la route c'est vrai que si on
était avec lauré avec le rêve de
téléphone à tripoter les mails tout ça
c'est sûr que là la tension allait gifi
d'une seconde pour pour que la
catastrophe arrive je vous laisse la
parole pour peut-être réagir aussi à
cette autre mesure en tant que membre de
l'association victimes de la route dans
les yvelines
cette réaction à l'interdiction
d'interdire le stationnement à moins de
cinq mètres d'un passage piéton oui ça
c'est tout à fait une très bonne mesure
parce que bon que c'est une voiture dont
c'est pas très haut on peut voir et je
prends l'exemple des camionnettes de
livraison ou des gens qui travaillent
des cabinets kilomètres près des
passages piétons les gens traversent ils
n'ont aucune visibilité le conducteur
qui lui arrive aussi il n'a aucune
visibilité qui fait kéba par la force
des choses le piéton s'engage et
personne voit l'autre ce qui fait que
les deux dans les deux cas c'est messi
c'est une très bonne mesure je trouve
que c'est très très bien toute une
batterie de mesures qui était annoncée
malgré tout est ce qu'on a appris à
cohabiter parce que le ministre a
rappelé que les piétons les cyclistes
étaient les plus touchés est ce que le
essentielle ça serait pas aussi de dans
le cadre de la pédagogie d' apprendre à
cohabiter sur la route et que les
automobilistes se rendre compte qu'ils
ne sont pas tout seuls mais tout c'est
tout l'ensemble de ces mesures visent
bien évidemment aussi les piétons et les
cyclistes celle dont vous n'êtes parler
à l'instance pour les passages piétons
c'est bien évidemment les piétons et
dans toute l' dans le volet prévention
des des quatre familles de mesures que
le ministre a annoncées
ça s'adresse non seulement aux
automobilistes mais bien évidemment
aussi aux piétons et aux cyclistes
il y en a pour tout le monde et
aujourd'hui on arrive à cohabiter sur la
route est ce qu'il ya une amélioration
sait-on cyclistes automobilistes alors
si vous me permettez je vais vous dire
sur les mauvais chiffres de l'année
dernière mais le 2014
pourquoi y at il eu de mauvais chiffres
à mon avis c'est pas parce que nos
concitoyens sont devenus mauvais
conducteurs subitement depuis 2013 mais
je pense que la météo y est pour
beaucoup
nous avons eu tout le monde le sait 2014
a été l'année la plus chaude depuis que
la météo nationale existe
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de journées de
gel il ya eu peu de neige au moins dans
les yvelines en tout cas mais dans
l'ensemble de la france et donc il ya eu
plus de monde sur la voie publique et en
particulier plus de piétons et plus de
cyclistes
forcément quand il tombe pas des cordes
quand il neige pas quand il n'ya pas de
verglas on sort son vélo et fatalement
il ya plus d'accidents
et ça ça se trouve en enfin les
statistiques ne mentent pas dès qu'il y
a un beau temps ou pas mauvais temps il
ya plus d'accidents donc est d'ailleurs
le ministre l'expliquent lui-même
puisque l'augmentation du nombre de tués
ce sont surtout des piétons des
cyclistes et les cyclomotoristes pour
revient sur cette question de la
cohabitation des modules de
sensibilisation dans les écoles ce sont
deux choses
oui c'est bon on voit beaucoup de jeunes
je parie que le petit en coulisses c'est
vrai qu effectivement les la
cohabitation est difficile parce que
tous veulent la chaussée c'est vrai il
ya aussi des piétons et aussi des
cyclistes qui font malheureusement des
erreurs de conduite
moi j'en vois tous les matins qui
traverse un carrefour sans visibilité
dans le noir habillé avec des vêtements
foncés sans lumière c'est aussi il met
aussi un peu lent leur vie en danger
quelque part c'est le ton mobilis tu ne
le voit pas et est aussi fort et c'est
tout le monde apprenne que la sécurité
c'est pour tout le monde que les autres
mu avait tout dans les piétons aussi et
les cyclistes aussi et les
cyclomotoristes aussi qu'attendez-vous
de cette de ces nouvelles mesures quel
résultat peut-on en attendre c'est la
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est notre question du jour
je pense que par rapport à l'alcool
c'est bien parce que il y en a beaucoup
qui font pas attention il ya beaucoup
d'accidents par rapport à l'alcool
surtout chez les jeunes donc je pense
que c'est une bonne mesure prise du
portable
bah ouais je suis tout à fait d'accord
parce que passé on n'a pas la même
vigilance que canton
on est 100 voilà autant pour le portable
que l'oreillette faut pas que ça empêche
non plus les automobilistes de rouler
sereinement mais mais quelque part c'est
pour la santé tous donc c'est plutôt
bien je pense que c'est une bonne chose
je constate en particulier qui a peu de
gens qui respectent les limitations de
vitesse plutôt contre après si c'est
vraiment dissuasif je dis pourquoi pas
pour moi surtout ouais c'est plutôt pour
certains je pense quoi plutôt pour se
faire de l'argent
apparemment c'est ce qu'elle disait ce
dernier à ce dernier saint quentinois
mais globalement en tout cas les mesures
sont sont appréciées sont comprises
puisqu'il faut à réduire le nombre de
tués sur la route c'est cela va de soi
malgré tout il ya eu cette augmentation
vous nous l'avez expliqué
tout à l'air est ce que ça veut pas
aussi dire qu'il ya un problème de
prévention
alors j'ai parlé de la météo évidemment
pas attendre qu'il fasse mauvais et puis
en attendant que ça vienne il faut faire
quelque chose dans le domaine de la
prévention
notre association fait déjà tout ce
qu'elle peut en tout cas en particulier
dans les écoles les collèges et les
lycées comme vous le disiez monsieur
pour sensibiliser les jeunes femmes d
éduquer les jeunes en particulier pour
le piétons vélos et cyclomoteurs
oui il ya un problème de prévention la
répression ne suffit pas il faut de la
prévention mais la prévention tout seul
malheureusement ne suffira pas donc il
faut aussi une répression accrue il n'y
a pas de doute
votre vision sur sa sur la question de
la répression la prévention par rapport
à votre association victimes de la route
bah disons qu'on voit au coc doit plus
en plus de gens bas qui sont victimes
d'actions de la route qui sont renversés
et tout ça et c'est vrai qu
effectivement bas toutes ces mesures
vont dans le sens où il faut apprendre
vraiment à cohabiter et la route est un
espace où tout on y vit pour les
diverses déplacement mais il faut plus
de prévention la répression il faut les
deux il faut les deux il faut il faut de
l'éducation des gens au plus jeune âge
de telle manière que ses tous ces acquis
puisse servir pour plus tard il faut que
la répression ne soutient pas de
répression derrière ça absolument rien
pour avancer un petit peu par rapport
aux différentes mesures on va pas
dresser la liste des 26 mai malgré tout
il y en a une dont on n'a pas encore
parlé ce sont la suppression c'est la
suppression des obstacles dangereux les
préfets qui vont être en charge de
repérer les routes dangereuses dans les
départements pour retirer les obstacles
les arbres les poteaux les glissières de
sécurité par exemple ça va c'est un
travail qui va se faire avec les
associations par exemple est-ce que vous
allez être sollicités pour tout ça alors
je veux dire cette mesure elle existe
déjà mais je sais c'est bien aux préfets
de prendre les mesures pour assurer la
la bonne sécurité de la voirie
apparemment il y aurait une vigilance
accrue en tout cas où ce qu'on veut on
veut en faire plus qu'à écouter si on
nous demande notre avis nous le donnons
vous avez des idées déjà par exemple sur
le département des yvelines des endroits
accidentogènes de parts d obstacle
dangereux non notre association
ne se concentrent de ne se concentre pas
sur ce genre de problème pourrions
peut-être le faire mais c'est pas
l'orientation que nous avons prises au
moins dans les yvelines
nous je vous dis nous intervenons
beaucoup plus en milieu scolaire et puis
dans les entreprises mais relativement
peu directement sur la voirie c'est bien
le rôle des maires et du préfet en
particulier et du conseil général
enfin tous les fonctionnaires qui sont
chargés de cette mission là sur vous
demande notre avis nul de londres mais
c'est pas notre tâche prioritaire
vous êtes sollicité pas de par votre
association votre fonction au sein de
l'association pour la prévention pour
donner votre avis sur les wii les routes
sur la circulation
wim sur l'association se meut sur
versailles nous avons été présentés sur
les différents quartiers vont être élus
de conseillers de quartier et sur wii
quartier de versailles ils ont pas en
sur 7
donc nous intervenons aussi auprès des
gens de la mairie pour leur dire les
endroits qui pourraient tout ça pour
être amélioré on pourrait éventuellement
changer quelque chose
ce qu'on s'est aperçu s'il ya un sens et
qui va pas ou les vélos qui vont dans un
sens et voitures dans l'autre plein de
petites choses qui pue qui au jour le
jour
facilite la vie tourne avec en
respectant la sécurité bien entendu
j'aimerais que les zones 30 en ville
beaucoup de gens ont envie race 30 alors
oui mais ça permet à tout le monde de
passer c'est souvent dans les endroits
et les écoles les écoles basse et les
enfants un enfant ça échappe très vite à
ses parents et ça va très vite sur la
route donc c'est vrai que plus les
mesures de prévention est alors à
apprendre ça va exactement dans le bon
sens et on l'espère nous un haut niveau
notre association on intervient après
l'accident
c'est à dire qu'on vient en aide aux
victimes auprès les assurances auprès
des tribunaux ou auprès des médecins en
quoi tout ça donc on a un recul dessus
on sait ce qui s'est passé donc voilà on
peut éventuellement dire voilà à cet
endroit là s'il ya eu ça si vous avez si
on pouvait améliorer vous permet
d'obtenir des aménagements les accidents
ne se reproduisent pas on n'est pas un
autre merci à tous les deux d'être venu
commenter ces mesures annoncées par le
ministre en début de semaine ses 26
mesures pour lutter contre la mortalité
sur les routes avec les chiffres qui
n'ont pas été particulièrement bons pour
l'année 2014
merci encore nous poursuivrons le
journal avec un mot de politique le
député des yvelines benoît hamon qui a
adressé pour la première fois depuis son
arrivée dans l'hémicycle ses voeux aux
personnalités c'était hier à trappes
commune où il siège également dans la
majorité
il est revenu sur le retrait du projet
ski d'omaha elancourt qu'il a salué il a
aussi regretté que la communauté
d'agglomération de 50
on ne se tourne pas vers une fusion avec
le plateau de saclay sur le plan
national il a aussi réagi aux propos du
premier ministre manuel valls qui a
qualifié la situation en france au
lendemain des attentats d'apartheid a
qualifié d' apartheid
la situation française appelle des
politiques publiques vigoureuse a
prévenu l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
l'éducation justement à présent et le
salon de l'étudiant qui vient de se
tenir à versailles alors que le service
est d'admission postbac se met en place
en ce moment sur internet ils étaient
donc nombreux à venir chercher des
informations pour ne surtout pas se
tromper d'orientation c'était le
week-end dernier mélanie poké et david
charpentier
je vois les choses c'est qu'on a envie
de faire
on a envie d'étudier ne pas viser
forcément choisir en fonction de ses
goûts une phrase qui prend tout son sens
au moment de décider son orientation
parce que la sélection sur admission
post bac n'est pas anodine
apb donc va étudier tous les deux
formulé par les jeunes donc à même dans
un même temps et donc donnera une
réponse et une seule à tous les voeux
formulés
selon le rang le positionnement du voeu
sur une liste bien déterminé que le
jeune aura formules et donc atb cherche
à donner la meilleure réponse possible
du moins le voeu le mieux placé dans la
liste pour satisfaire les demandes du
jeune il faut donc ne pas hésiter à
mettre en premier voeu la formation
qu'on souhaite vraiment étudié les à six
mois du bac
pas toujours facile de décider je suis
en terminale et je sais pas encore trop
quoi faire pour l'année prochaine
donc j'en ai ici pour trouver des idées
raphaël hésitent encore la communication
ou la psychologie l'intéressent même
s'il le reconnaît lui-même cela n'a rien
à voir mais ce qui l'inquiète c'est apb
c'est ce qui va faire pencher la balance
après pour
pour notre avenir mais faut se dépêcher
c'est la bbc c'est précis c'est le délai
pour le remplir il est assez court du
coup
faut avoir des idées très rapidement les
futurs bacheliers ont jusqu'au 20 mars
pour faire leurs voeux ils peuvent en
changer l'ordre jusqu'au 31 mai de quoi
tout de même relativiser et toujours
dans le domaine de l'éducation le
conseil général annonce avoir équipé
avec l'académie de versailles 9 espaces
numériques de travail dans les collèges
du département notamment celui de
maurepas le collège alexandre dumas une
expérimentation de dix mois qui va
permettre de tester les échanges entre
parents enseignants élèves cela
permettra à chacun de consulter emploi
du temps encore les cours et les
ressources pédagogiques économie société
et la création d'un service d'échangé
local à versailles et rendre des
services pour amasser des points qui
permettront ensuite d'obtenir pour soi
même des services de l'aide pour
d'autres tâches
les explications sur ce système le sel
avec williams elle et elodie moines
c'est à côté est il y avait des moments
extrêmement une fois mais je pense que
je dirais jamais vu mais c'est plutôt
date envoyer c'est un cours particulier
un peu spécial que la thalie reçoit
aujourd'hui avec les à elles sont toutes
deux adhérents du service d'échangé
local de versailles un système d'
échanges de services entre les membres
on a adhéré mon mari et moi au sel il ya
à peu près un mois l'idée c'était de
d'échanger des services avec des gens
qu'on connaît pas avec un aspect non
économiques en particulier l'idée cet
après midi c'était d'avoir des
informations un peu pointu ce que moi
j'ai envie d'avoir quelque chose d'un
peu oui pointu sur le changement
climatique
il se trouve que dans le sel on a une
pro ici les services ne se monnaie pas
en euros
les en soleil une monnaie virtuelle
utilisée par les adhérents du sel de
versailles une minute équivaut à un
soleil donc pour une heure de cours
nathalie va payer 60 soleil aléas
le créateur du sel de versailles serono
en dieu lancé il ya quelques mois la
plateforme compte aujourd'hui une
quarantaine d'adhérents
une fois qu'ils sont inscrits sur le
système sur le site il déclare donc
toutes leurs offres et leurs demandes et
après tous les autres adhérents peuvent
voir leur offre à la demande et donc les
contacter soit pour dire ben voilà ta
teloche ça m'intéresse tu sais un peu
bricolé ben voilà ça m'intéresse il peut
venir chez moi pour faire ceci se mette
d'accord
après entre eux de façon individuelle
indépendamment du système comme le
feraient eux deux personnes qui se
rencontrent dans la rue ça veut dire
qu'il y en a un qui va chez l'autre ils
font le service qui était prévu et puis
après ils reviennent sur les systèmes
pour déclarer comptabilisés en quelque
sorte leurs échanges
un système de soleil qui fonctionne
comme un vrai compte en banque
car il est même possible d'être à
découvert moi par exemple je suis à -400
soleil depuis j'ai commencé j'ai fait
c'est moi qui ai fait le plus échanges
j'ai beaucoup donné mais j'ai aussi
beaucoup reçu j'ai beaucoup sollicités
et donc logiquement je suis en négatif
cette fois c'est renault qui va gagner
quelques soleil il va rencontrer les a
pour lui donner des leçons de cuisine
voilà ça c'est des petits lardons et des
pruneaux en fait j'aime et légumes que
j'ai sous la main
donc ça peut être chaud ce après un
cours de 30 minutes pour lequel l'état
devra débourser 30 soleil je pense que
link est pour moi c'est le lien est plus
important que les biens qu'est ce que je
recherche avec mes deux enfants c'est le
baby sitting
donc j'ai c'est lui qui me laisse
suffisamment de soleil de prendre un
baby sitter et je trouve avec russell
j'ai plus de confiance parce que c'est
en raison des gens qui connaissent et
c'est pas un liste je connais aucune
issue
je connais je sais que quelqu'un ça ne
se reconnaît le personne qui fait du
baby sitting donc c'est vraiment un lien
de confiance du déménagement au
dépannage de plomberie
ici la variété d'offres ne manquent pas
le service d'échangé local un système
conviviale basée sur la confiance et ont
chacun trouve son compte
culture en ce mercredi jusqu'au 1er mars
vous pourrez découvrir le travail du
japonais yuki inoue à guyancourt une
centaine de visages qui l' a sculpté
dans la pierre sont exposés rencontre
avec l'artiste des dizaines de visages
s'observe silencieusement avec une
émotion figé dans la pierre une pierre
du japon cher à yuki chine où est cette
roche volcanique blanche de l'île
d'okinawa
témoin du temps qui passe comme cette
célèbre bataille de 1945 pour cette
bataille
mon père qui a été mon appel à un ter
étaient mobilisés et puis a été tué en
tant qu'artisan à un soldat de deuxième
classe
d'ailleurs moi je connaissais pas mon
père parce qu'il était très jeune notre
petit quoi donc cette histoire
pour moi ok navarre a toujours attaché à
cause de cette histoire disant entier
monsieur goulet pour l'exposition mille
et une tête yuki chine os culte des
centaines de visages dans son matériau
de prédilection comme des instantanés
pris sur le vif la tête quand même c'est
une honte c'est un symbole de l'histoire
de l'homme
et puis l'on m'a dit et à sculpter des
puits millions d'années les bouffer des
dettes soit sur la pierre ou soir avec
le bois donc le tête c'est un symbole de
l'histoire passée et puis lui soit
l'animation une histoire modelé par le
temps et les hommes à l'image du travail
de yuki chine hu et matériels directs
dans la pierre frappez dégrossi réponse
est pour révéler une forme dans la roche
l'histoire inscrite dans la matière cet
acte de commandes s'est cassé brisé deux
blocs
pour moi c'est une sorte d' or comme
histoire qu'on a on à répéter toujours
la paix et la dr honteux monde u-17
l'option destruction et puis le
consultions ce paradoxe
que je plaisante cette manière après je
travaille j'ai recollé recomposée en ce
moment là je me sens vraiment juge il
est pas d'après la légende japonaise du
temple des mille et un bouddha on
pouvait retrouver dans le visage des
statuts les traits des êtres chers
éloignés ou décédés you chisinau s
inspire de cette histoire pour ses
sculptures guardian de l'éternité de
l'homme et des empreintes successives du
temps qui passe
dans un instant sur tv fils qui est ce
que le magazine culturel de la rédaction
présentée par catherine soula torrents d
vous demain 18h pour un nouveau journal
toujours en direct très bonne soirée
vous